we're on problem 173
the probability is one half that a
certain coin will turn up heads on any
given toss fair enough
if the koi if the coin is to be tossed
three times what is the probability that
on at least one of the tosses the co the
coin will turn up tails
so probability
at least
one tails
and that might seem really hard for you
how do i know which tails it is and all
of that let's think about the opposite
circumstance there
this is equivalent to saying
what is the probability that i don't get
don't get all heads
right these are equivalent things at
least one tails means that i don't get
all heads and what is the probability
that i don't get all heads well that's
one minus the probability that i get all
heads
right
and figuring out the probability that
you get all heads isn't that hard
because you have to get you have a half
probability of heads on the first time
times a half probability that because
you have to get heads on the second time
times a half probability because you
have to get a heads on the third time
and that's equal to one eighth
so one minus one eighth is equal to
eight eighths minus one eighth which is
equal to seven eighths
so that is choice d
and a lot of these probability questions
you have to get at least one of
something if you think of it that way
it's very hard and you'll have to start
thinking of combinatorics and and
binomial coefficients and all that but
if you just think of the opposite
problem what's the
what would have to be true that i don't
get all heads what's the probability
that i do get all heads and then that's
a much easier thing to solve for and
then you just take that from one and you
get the probability that it doesn't
happen
next question
174 of the final grades received by the
students in a certain math course
one-fifth
ras
one-fourth
are b's
one half
are c's
and the remaining ten grades
ten grades are d's
what's the number of the students in the
course so if we know what fraction 10 is
and we know the number of students in
the course so essentially let's see what
what are these fractions add up to so
let's find a common denominator looks
like the common denominator between 4 5
and 2 is 20.
so
one-fifth i get a so that's four
twenties
four twenties plus one-fourth so that's
five twenties plus one-half that's ten
twenties
so the a b's and c's are
equal to what is this 4 plus 5 is 9 plus
10 is equal to 19 20 of the class
and they're saying that the remaining 10
grades are d's there are no f's in this
class so these the remaining grades
that's one twentieth of the class so
that's equal to one twentieth right
because if the a's b and c's are 19 20
it's and all the other grades are d's
then all the other grades are going to
be 1 20 of the class because that's
what's left over so if i say 1 20th of
the class is equal to 10 multiply both
sides by 20 and you get the class is
equal to 200
students and that's choice d
next question 175
as x increases from 165 to 166
so as x goes
from
to
which of the following must increase
interesting
so 1 2x
minus 5.
well sure as i go from 2 times 165 to 2
times 166 this is obviously going to
increase and this is going to stay the
same so this is going to increase
2 and you can substitute the numbers in
there if you don't believe me but i
think that should make some intuition
statement 2
1 minus 1 over
x
so
one's one over one sixty five
one over one sixty five
is greater than
one over one sixty six
right
this is a larger fraction than that is
you know one over a million is much
smaller than one over two so one over 65
is greater than one over 66
so you might say oh as i go from one
over 65 to one over as i go from 165 to
this term right here gets smaller
right
that term gets there does get smaller
but we're subtracting that term so for
subtracting a term that's getting
smaller the whole value is actually
going to get larger we're subtracting a
smaller number as we go to 166.
1 minus 1 over 166 is a larger number
than 1 minus 1 over 165. so this also
gets larger
statement 3.
one over
x squared
minus x
so the question is what happens to x
squared minus x as we go from 165 to
166.
and if you think about it
we are well beyond any type of you know
x squared any kind of vertex in this i
mean if you know a little bit of
calculus you could figure out the vertex
really fast so we're you know this is
going to be some type of a parabola this
x squared minus x it's going to look
something like this
right and
its vertex is actually let's see 2x
minus 1 is equal to zero its vertex is
at x is equal to
one half it's a very small number so
we're in the we're in the point of this
curve that's increasing upwards right so
when we go from 165 to 166
this right here is definitely increasing
this this denominator is definitely
going to increase from 165 to 166. you
might say oh well we're going to be
subtracting a larger number but that's
more than offset by squaring the larger
number so this denominator is going to
increase but if the denominator is
increasing then the whole fraction which
is the inverse of the denominator that's
going to decrease so this one is not
increasing
so 1 and 2 only so that's c
next question 176. i'll do it in a
different color
6.
a rectangular box is 10 inches wide 10
inches long and 5 inches high
so it's 10 inches
10 inches and then 5 high
fair enough
that's the box
what is the greatest possible distance
in inches between any two points on the
box
so this is a bit of an old
trick so the longest distance in this
box is is kind of three-dimensional
diagonal so you might so normal diagonal
goes along one surface but if you go
from this point back here and i'll do
that in a different different color to
this point over here that's the longest
dimension in the box
and if you know how to figure out
distance in three dimensions then
that's all you really need to know how
to do it's going to be the square root
of 10 squared plus 10 squared plus 5
squared and so that's the fast way to do
it and i'll show you the logic of it in
a second so 10 squared plus 10 squared
plus 5 squared if we had a fourth
dimension which is hard to visualize we
would add that distance squared and take
the square root of everything
and so this is equal to the square root
of what 100 225 225 which is equal to
15 and that's choice a but let me give
you the logic so if i'm taking the
distance from this point to this point
how do we figure that out
well let's see the easiest way to think
about it is
can we figure out
this distance
right here so this is going along the
top of the box let me do that in the
magenta
this diagonal that's along the top of
the box well sure if we look at the box
straight down what i just drew if this
is 10
and 10 what i just drew goes like that
right it's going along the top of the
box
so this is going to be the square root
of 100 squared
the square root of 10 squared plus the
square root of 10 squared
so this just pythagorean theorem
this distance right here is the square
root of 200.
right i just used the pythagorean
theorem i just said this is 10
this is 10 so this is half to this has
to be the square root of 200.
now we have to do a little bit of
visualization
to figure out that green line that's the
longest diagonal in this box
think about it this way we we still have
a right triangle although maybe it's a
little harder to visualize maybe it
isn't so the right triangle looks like
this
it looks like this
where this side is the square root of
200 that's this up here
this side right here
is five they tell us that so this side
right here is five
and then the diagonal that we're trying
to solve for is in green
that's the longest diagonal
and if we did it
remember this line is the same thing if
you view from the top as this line it's
just you can't see what's below it so
here we just use the pythagorean theorem
so we could say c squared let's call
this c
is equal to 25
plus this squared plus 200 and then you
get to the same answer that we just got
to so c
is equal to the square root of 225
which is equal to 15.
and that was
what problem was i on that was for
choice a if i haven't already said it
anyway see you in the next video